It's a school trying to do the right thing, a school trying something new, trying to keep its students safe. So they bought handguns, seven of them, Glock 9mm, to use if a shooter comes into their building. And a week and a half before school started, after a bunch of training, they were running their first drill in the school building with their guns, fresh out of the boxes.
这所学校正试图做正确的事，尝试新的方法，努力确保学生的安全。因此，他们购买了七把9毫米格洛克手枪，以便在枪手进入校园时使用。在开学前一周半，经过多次训练后，他们在校内进行了第一次演习，使用的是刚拆封的枪支。
Here, look at them, make sure they're all loading. Look at them. They all should be.
看这里，检查一下，确保它们都装好了弹药。看看它们。它们都应该是装好的。
The building's mostly empty, no kids around. It's a district in rural Ohio that let us record on the condition that we not say their name on the air. It's eight people on this team. Only two teachers volunteered for it.
教学楼里基本没人，没有孩子。这是俄亥俄州农村的一个学区，他们允许我们录音的前提是不在广播中透露校名。这个团队有八个人，只有两名教师自愿参加。
The rest are a guidance counselor, two custodians, and the three administrators who run the school. One of them is the only woman on the team. Producer Lisa Pollak watched them doing this. Lisa, so explain how this works exactly.
其余成员包括一名辅导员、两名后勤人员和三名学校管理人员。其中一人是队里唯一的女性。制片人丽莎·波拉克观看了他们的演练。丽莎，解释一下这到底是怎么运作的。
OK, so the seven guns are locked in these small safes that have been installed in locations all over the school. I saw them run a bunch of drills. And in all of them, the goal was to run to the nearest safe, get the gun out of the safe, and then get to where the shooter is as soon as possible. And they time each drill.
好的，这七把枪被锁在校园各处安装的小型保险柜里。我看了他们进行的一系列演习。在所有演习中，目标都是跑到最近的保险柜，取出枪支，然后尽快赶到枪手所在的位置。他们会对每次演习计时。
OK. We're going to play a tape of this. I just want to warn listeners there are loud gunshots from blanks that they fired during these drills.
好的。我们要播放一段录音。我得提醒听众，演习过程中会有发射空包弹发出的巨大枪声。
So the first little glitch they came to was that some of the team members actually had trouble getting into the safes. You have to put your finger on the sensor.
他们遇到的第一个小故障是，一些队员在打开保险柜时遇到了困难。你必须把手指放在传感器上。
It's like a fingerprint thing?
就像指纹识别那样吗？
Right. And it's a little tricky.
对。这有点棘手。
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
It's not working.
没反应。
[BEEPING]
[哔哔声]
[MAN SPEAKING ON RADIO]
[对讲机里的男子说话声]
There's a sheriff's deputy. He's playing the shooter.
那是一名治安官副手。他正在扮演枪手。
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
I'm following a guy named John. He's the principal for grade six through 12. He's running from his office, darts by the cafeteria. He's got a gun. He's wearing a bulletproof vest. He's holding a walkie talkie, very focused, very aware the clock is ticking. He's told me that every few seconds in of one of these shootings, another kid can be killed.
我跟着一个叫约翰的人。他是六到十二年级的校长。他从办公室跑出来，冲过食堂。他带着枪，穿着防弹背心，手里拿着对讲机，非常专注，非常清楚时间正在流逝。他告诉我，在这些枪击事件中，每过几秒钟，就可能有一个孩子丧命。
Nothing this way, nothing this way.
这边没人，那边也没人。
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
Elementary wing, it's in the elementary wing.
小学部，在小学部。
Elementary wing, the body from [INAUDIBLE].
小学部，来自[听不清]的尸体。
The shooter's in the elementary wing.
枪手在小学部。
Elementary wing-- the building also has middle school and high school.
小学部——这栋楼里还有初中和高中。
Right. So the principal's running down the hallway, and he's just about to get to the area where the elementary kids are. But there's a door there, and it's locked. This happens automatically when the school goes into lockdown. So he and the two guys with him are stuck. He fumbles for his keys, and he's trying to find the right one.
对。所以校长正跑在走廊上，眼看就要到达小学生所在的区域。但那里有一扇门，而且锁上了。当学校进入封锁状态时，门会自动上锁。所以他和随行的两个人被困住了。他摸索着钥匙，试图找到正确的那把。
Yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
对。[听不清]。
He's trying to unlock the door.
他正在尝试开门。
Here we go.
好了，来了。
[GUNSHOT]
[枪声]
Jesus.
天哪。
Behind you.
在你后面。
All right. Here we go. There we go.
好了。准备好了。这就行了。
Door opens. They're on the elementary school side. And they find the shooter right there. So that's the goal of the exercise. They got there. And they don't pretend to shoot him or anything. They're just timing the response. And it wasn't great.
门开了。他们到了小学部那边。他们就在那发现了枪手。这就是演习的目标。他们到达了。他们并没有假装开枪之类的。他们只是在记录反应时间。结果不太理想。
That was an eternity compared to the first time.
和第一次比起来，这次简直像过了一个世纪。
Yeah. Oh, yeah, it was because you got to get through the doors.
是啊。哦，是的，因为你得穿过那些门。
All clear. Thank you for your cooperation.
一切安全。谢谢您的配合。
Lisa, it's so controversial to put guns into a school. Like, why did they choose to do it here? Like, why did that seem like the best option to them?
丽莎，在学校里放枪太有争议了。他们为什么要选择这么做？为什么这在他们看来是最好的选择？
Well, I talked to John, the principal, about this.
嗯，我和校长约翰谈过这件事。
Yeah.
是吗。
For a long time, he agreed with people who think guns in schools is a bad idea. And even now, he doesn't think it's something that's right for every school. He says he's not a gun guy, didn't grow up with guns, had never used one. Then he came to this school. And this school is pretty remote, in an area that doesn't even have its own police force. So if a shooter got in the building, they could be waiting a long time for help.
很长一段时间里，他都赞同那些认为在学校持枪是不好的主意的人。即使是现在，他也不认为这适合每所学校。他说他不是个枪迷，没在枪支环境下长大，也从未用过枪。后来他来到了这所学校。学校位置相当偏远，所在的地区甚至没有自己的警察部队。所以如果枪手进入校园，他们可能要等待很长时间才能得到救援。
I don't know that I was necessarily sold that this was the right thing to do, but what are we going to do? We're 15 minutes away from an ambulance being here. We're 15 minutes away from a sheriff department being here. We're 15 minutes away-- you worry. You worry because you realize that you're on your own.
我不确定这是否一定是正确的做法，但我们还能做什么呢？救护车赶到这里需要15分钟。治安官部门赶到这里需要15分钟。这需要15分钟——你会担心的。你会担心，因为你意识到一切只能靠自己。
And so I wanted to learn. And so I went out and started learning how to shoot a gun and how to handle a gun, and-- which is different. The first time you shoot a gun, that's pretty scary. It was scary to me.
所以我想学习。我就去开始学习如何射击和操控枪支，这和以前完全不同。你第一次开枪时，那真的很可怕。对我来说很可怕。
After that, he went through a lot of training, including one class where he was really forced to think through what it would mean, in a very literal way, to have to shoot someone in school. In one exercise, the instructor said--
在那之后，他参加了大量培训，其中包括一节课程，他被迫在非常现实的层面上思考在学校里不得不向某人开枪意味着什么。在一次演习中，教官说——
You need to walk up to the target till as close as you can. And he says, and in your mind, you have to envision this as a shooter in your cafeteria, and there's students all around. How close do you have to get before you're confident you're going to hit that target? You've got to shoot that target, and you can't miss.
你需要走到离目标尽可能近的地方。他说，在你的脑海里，你必须把这想象成食堂里的枪手，周围全是学生。你必须靠近到什么程度才有信心击中目标？你必须击中目标，而且不能失手。
I can't miss. Because if I miss, there's a possibility of somebody else getting hurt. All right? And I can't let that happen. I can't let it be me who hurts a student in my school.
我不能失手。因为如果我失手了，就有可能伤及他人。明白吗？我不能让这种事发生。我不能让学校里的学生因为我而受伤。
Though, of course, he might have to shoot one of his students. In a lot of these shootings, that's who the shooter is.
当然，他可能不得不向自己的学生开枪。在很多这类枪击事件中，枪手就是学生。
If you had told me years ago that this is what I'd be advocating or thinking, I wouldn't have believed you. But these things don't stop happening. They just continue to happen.
如果你几年前告诉我这就是我所倡导或思考的，我绝不会相信。但这些事情并没有停止发生，它们一直在持续。
These shootings do just continue to happen. Today on our program, we have all kinds of people trying to figure out what to do to prepare, like the staff at this school. In general, it seems to plan for disaster, school administrators and others look at previous shootings. They look to the past to anticipate the future, knowing full well the whole time there's a limit to what any planning can accomplish. If a shooter gets into a school, the sad fact is you cannot stop every tragic possibility. You can't stop everything.
这些枪击事件确实在持续发生。今天在我们的节目中，各行各业的人都在试图找出准备的方法，就像这所学校的教职工一样。总的来说，为了应对灾难，学校管理人员和其他人似乎倾向于参考过去的枪击事件。他们通过回顾过去来预测未来，同时非常清楚任何计划所能实现的效果都是有限的。如果枪手进入学校，可悲的事实是你无法阻止每一种悲剧的可能。你无法阻止一切。
Act one of our show today, we have people who are trying to learn from the past. They're trying to put in measures. They're trying to be as thoughtful and thorough as they possibly can, and it's still not enough. Act two, we have people who have invented something that actually seems to work and help.
在我们今天节目的第一部分，我们采访了一些试图从过去汲取经验的人。他们试图采取措施，尽可能做到周全和彻底，但依然不够。在第二部分，我们会介绍一些发明了切实有效且有帮助的东西的人。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act one, "Ready As You'll Never Be." For any school that's trying to figure out the best ways to prepare for a gunman, there's an example out there that might be really helpful, and that's Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School in Parkland, Florida. Just a month before the shooting that killed 17 people in that school, the teachers trained their students on new procedures they should follow in that exact situation. This came after a total overhaul of the school's emergency response planning. And the day of the shooting in a television interview, one of the teachers reflected on the effectiveness of that training.
第一部分，“做好最坏的准备”。对于任何试图找出准备应对枪手最佳方法的学校来说，佛罗里达州帕克兰市的玛乔丽·斯通曼·道格拉斯高中提供了一个非常有参考价值的案例。就在造成该校17人死亡的枪击事件发生前一个月，老师们刚刚针对那种确切的情况对学生进行了新程序的培训。这是在学校全面修订应急响应计划之后进行的。在枪击事件发生当天的电视采访中，其中一位老师反思了这次培训的有效性。
But I don't think we could have been more prepared than we were today. And I mean, they knew what to do and we knew what to do. And even still, even with that, we still have 17 casualties, 17 people that aren't going to return to their families. [CRYING] And to me, that's totally unacceptable.
但我认为我们已经做好了能做到的最充足的准备。我是说，他们知道该做什么，我们也知道该做什么。即便如此，我们还是有17名伤亡者，17个人再也回不到家人身边了。[哭泣] 对我来说，这是完全不可接受的。
Did the training they received save lives that day or didn't it? It's actually an open question. One of our producers, Robyn Semien, went to Parkland to talk to the teachers about what was actually in the training and how well it did or did not prepare them for what they went through.
他们那天接受的培训到底有没有挽救生命？这实际上是一个悬而未决的问题。我们的制片人之一罗宾·塞米恩去了帕克兰，与老师们谈论了培训的具体内容，以及它在多大程度上为他们所经历的危机做好了准备。
The training they did at Stoneman Douglas High School was an attempt to be as prepared as possible for a wide range of emergencies-- bomb threats, hurricane warnings, a bank robber nearby, an active shooter. Douglas is a school with 11 buildings and over 3,000 students, so upgrading all their emergency procedures took months to plan and coordinate with faculty and district officers, police and fire departments.
斯通曼·道格拉斯高中的培训旨在为各种紧急情况做好尽可能充足的准备——炸弹威胁、飓风预警、附近的银行抢劫，以及活跃枪手。道格拉斯是一所拥有11栋教学楼、超过3000名学生的学校，因此升级所有应急程序需要几个月的规划，并与教职员工、学区官员、警察和消防部门进行协调。
Melissa Falkowski teaches journalism at the high school. She's the teacher in that news clip you just heard. And the training was on her mind that night because she was on the committee that set it up. She's an enthusiastic teacher, a planner. She believes in a good hard think and being proactive.
梅丽莎·福尔科夫斯基在这所高中教新闻学。她就是你在刚才的新闻片段中听到的那位老师。那天晚上，培训一直萦绕在她心头，因为她就是设立培训委员会的成员。她是一位充满热情的教师，也是一个规划者。她坚信深思熟虑和主动作为。
Once she and the other teachers had been trained, they ran their students through all the new drills. The whole school did this over two days in January. Teachers were told--
一旦她和其他老师接受了培训，他们就带领学生进行了所有新的演习。全校在一月份用了两天时间完成这些。老师们被告知——
We want you to go back to every single class. We know it's going to be annoying. We know the kids are going to get tired of hearing it by the time you get to the eighth period class because they're going to have heard it from every teacher, but they wanted us to go stand in front of the kids and go through all the emergency procedures. This is what we do for a fire.
我们希望你们回到每一个班级。我们知道这会很烦人。我们知道孩子们到第八节课时会厌倦听这些，因为他们已经从每个老师那里听过了，但他们还是希望我们站在孩子们面前，走一遍所有的应急程序。这就是我们遇到火灾时的做法。
For every period?
每一节课都要吗？
For every-- this is what a code black is. This is what we do--
每一——这就是黑色代码（code black）的含义。这就是我们做——
For two days?
持续两天？
For two days, we went over the procedures with the kids.
两天，我们和孩子们一起过了一遍程序。
Why did you have to do it with each and every class?
为什么你们必须对每一个班级都这样做？
Because they wanted to make sure that the kids knew the procedures, that it was ingrained in their mind and that they knew. So if they were absent on a silver day, they would get it on a burgundy day.
因为他们想确保孩子们了解这些程序，让它深入他们的脑海。所以如果他们如果在银色日子缺席，他们也会在酒红色的日子学到。
School colors, silver and burgundy. They're on an alternating schedule. Melissa says her kids took the drill seriously.
学校的校色是银色和酒红色。他们实行轮换时间表。梅丽莎说她的孩子们很认真地对待这次演习。
On a scale of 1 to 10--
如果满分是10分——
I would say we were totally prepared, like a 10.
我会说我们已经完全准备好了，像是10分。
The school told every teacher to cover the tall, rectangular windows on their classroom doors with paper, and leave the paper up all year. Just in case if there were one, it would make it harder for an active shooter to see in. That's a lesson from previous shootings. Get out of sight.
学校告诉每位老师用纸盖住教室门上高大的长方形窗户，并且整年都贴着纸。以防万一发生枪击，这会增加活跃枪手从外面向内窥视的难度。这是从以前的枪击事件中吸取的教训。远离视线。
Before Columbine, very few schools did active shooter drills. Now, nearly 20 years later, most of them do. Ashley Kurth teaches culinary at Douglas. She's levelheaded, pragmatic, like a person who's spent years working in busy restaurant kitchens, not losing her cool, which she did. Ashley remembers being trained with the other teachers on the new procedures last year. It started with them listening to 911 audio from Sandy Hook.
在科伦拜恩高中枪击事件之前，很少有学校进行活跃枪手演习。现在，近20年过去了，大多数学校都进行了这种演习。阿什利·库斯在道格拉斯高中教烹饪。她头脑冷静、务实，就像一个在繁忙餐厅厨房工作多年的人，不会惊慌失措。阿什利记得去年和其他老师一起接受了关于新程序的培训。开始时，他们听了来自桑迪胡克小学枪击案的911报警录音。
The audio is of, I believe, if I remember correctly, it's of the front office and one of the ladies that called in when the shooter is outside the door. And you can hear her, like-- her voice drops when she's like, he's right outside, he's right outside. And you can hear the dispatch officer telling her, you know, don't move and be quiet.
我相信，如果我没记错的话，录音里是前台办公室，其中一位女士在枪手在门外时报了警。你能听到她——当她说“他就在外面，他就在外面”时，她的声音变得很低沉。你能听到调度员告诉她，你知道，不要动，保持安静。
Hide, lock down. It's probably the most common response in schools all across the country. But out of Sandy Hook, another lesson. Schools told teachers, keep your classrooms locked all day, every day. Again, Melissa.
躲藏，封锁。这可能是全国学校中最常见的反应。但在桑迪胡克事件之后，又有了另一个教训。学校告诉老师：全天候保持教室门锁闭，每一天。还是梅丽莎。
That's kind of what they told us as they told us about Sandy Hook, how he went to the first classroom, the door was locked. He went to the second classroom, the door was locked. He went to the third classroom, the door was unlocked. And he stepped into that classroom, and he took advantage of that opportunity.
他们告诉我们桑迪胡克事件时就是这么说的：枪手走到第一个教室，门锁着；他走到第二个教室，门锁着；他走到第三个教室，门没锁。于是他走进那个教室，利用了那个机会。
And that's what I told my kids when we were preparing. I told them, I know it's going to be really annoying that the door's always going to be locked and you're going to have to knock. But I told them what they had told us in the training. And I said, I will not be the third door. Like, I will not be that third door.
我在准备时就是这么告诉孩子们的。我告诉他们，我知道门总是锁着的，你们得敲门会很烦人。但我把培训中告诉我们的情况传达给了他们。我说，我绝不会成为那第三扇门。我绝不会是那一扇门。
The details of this are not exactly right. At Sandy Hook, it was the front door and bathrooms that were locked. The classrooms weren't. But the lesson is the same, keep your door locked at all times.
这些细节并不完全准确。在桑迪胡克，锁着的是大门和洗手间。教室门并没有锁。但道理是一样的：随时保持门锁好。
Other details got hammered home, like what to do if a fire alarm goes off during a code red. The thinking on this is a lesson from the Jonesboro Middle School shooting in Arkansas 20 years ago. There were two shooters, both kids. One of them pulled a fire alarm to get the school to evacuate to a field, where from the woods, the boys shot at them. Five people died.
其他细节也被反复强调，比如如果在红色代码期间火警响起该怎么办。这一想法源于20年前阿肯色州琼斯伯勒中学枪击案的教训。当时有两个枪手，都是孩子。其中一个拉响了火警，让学校撤离到操场上，然后在树林里向他们射击。五人死亡。
In the training at Douglas, they addressed this exact thing. If a fire alarm and a code red happen to coincide, ignore the fire alarm, mind the code red. Ashley told her students--
在道格拉斯的培训中，他们专门讨论了这一点。如果火警和红色代码同时发生，忽略火警，执行红色代码。阿什利告诉她的学生——
The code red drill trumps all. If you hear a fire alarm go off, you stay put.
红色代码演习胜过一切。如果你听到火警响起，待在原地不动。
The main question from students, both Melissa and Ashley told me, what if I'm in the bathroom and I hear gunshots? What do I do then?
梅丽莎和阿什利都告诉我，学生们的主要疑问是：如果我在洗手间，听到枪声怎么办？那时候我该怎么做？
We told them to run. If you're out in the hallway and there's a code red, you have to find a place to hide yourself. So you either find a place to hide or you run, and you keep running, and you don't look back.
我们告诉他们跑。如果你在走廊上，遇到红色代码，你必须找个地方躲起来。所以你要么找个地方躲起来，要么跑，一直跑，不要回头。
You run. You run as far away as you can and as fast as you can away from the sound.
跑。尽可能跑远，以最快的速度远离声音。
Unlike Melissa, Ashley had been through this kind of training before at a school she taught at before Douglas. That school had a drill that really freaked Ashley out, with very loud, realistic sounds of gunfire. Ashley says there were blanks.
和梅丽莎不同，阿什利在去道格拉斯之前执教的学校接受过这种培训。那所学校进行了一次让阿什利真正感到恐惧的演习，伴随着非常大声、逼真的枪声。阿什利说那是空包弹。
The officer would walk around with blanks, and they would shoot. If the door was open, they'd go into the room and say, you're all dead in here.
警察会带着空包弹四处走动，然后射击。如果门是开着的，他们会走进房间说，你们这里所有人都死了。
Surprise drills with blanks, while not the norm, appeal to some schools who say there are benefits to learning how you'll act under pressure. But surprise drills with blanks are controversial. For one thing, they're disturbing.
带有空包弹的突击演习虽然不是常态，但吸引了一些学校，他们称这对学习如何在压力下行动有好处。但带有空包弹的突击演习是有争议的。首先，它们令人不安。
There have even been lawsuits about them. In one, a teacher claims she got PTSD after a man in a black hoodie came into her class, pointed a gun to her face, fired, and said, you're dead. The teacher heard a pop. She smelled smoke. She really thought she'd been shot. She had no idea it was a drill.
甚至还有过相关诉讼。在一宗案件中，一名教师声称她在一名穿着黑色连帽衫的男子走进她的教室，把枪指着她的脸，开火并说“你死了”之后患上了创伤后应激障碍。这位老师听到了一声砰响，闻到了烟味。她真的以为自己被枪击了。她根本不知道这是一次演习。
I talked to several school safety experts about these drills with blanks, these surprise drills that are hyperrealistic. None of them thought they're a good idea. One guy who trains teachers using video simulations told me that teachers who've been through one of these surprise drills perform worse on his simulations than teachers who have no training at all. They forget crucial steps, like calling the police, and commit more dangerous mistakes. Some find the blanks so upsetting they can't even finish the simulations.
我采访了几位学校安全专家，谈到了这些带有空包弹的演习，这些超级逼真的突击演习。他们没有人认为这是个好主意。一位使用视频模拟训练老师的人告诉我，经历过这些突击演习的老师在模拟中的表现比没有任何培训的老师更差。他们会忘记关键步骤，比如报警，并犯下更危险的错误。有些人觉得空包弹太让人心烦意乱，以至于无法完成模拟。
And there's a more basic problem with these surprise drills. If you know one is coming and you hear shots, how can you tell if it's a drill or the real thing? At Douglas, Ashley and Melissa both thought this was the kind of drill they'd have, unannounced with a fake shooter firing blanks. Ashley told her students that's what they should expect.
而且这些突击演习有一个更基本的问题。如果你知道演习要来，又听到枪声，你怎么分辨它是演习还是真的？在道格拉斯，阿什利和梅丽莎都认为这就是他们会进行的演习，即未经通知、带有假枪手发射空包弹。阿什利告诉她的学生，这就是他们应该预料到的。
Oh, yes, 100%. I told them, I said, it can happen at any point in time. So just be prepared that no matter which classroom you're in or where you're at, this could take place.
哦，是的，百分之百。我告诉他们，我说，这可能随时发生。所以无论你在哪个教室，或者你在哪里，都要做好准备，这可能发生。
They said it was going to sound real and feel real. I now have another faculty member who was at another high school in the district, and they did the active shooter training at her school, and they used blanks. It was simulated, and it felt real.
他们说听起来会很真实，感觉也很真实。我现在有另一位在学区另一所高中任教的同事，他们在她学校进行了活跃枪手培训，他们使用了空包弹。那是模拟的，但感觉很真实。
And so that's why a lot of people were like, is this the drill? Is this not the drill? But when you look at the time that it occurred, they don't run a drill at 2:25 in the afternoon, 15 minutes before we dismiss, and all these buses have to run kids all over the district.
这就是为什么很多人会问：这是演习吗？这不是演习吗？但看看它发生的时间，他们不会在下午2点25分，也就是放学前15分钟进行演习，那时候所有的校车都得把孩子送往全区各地。
Was that a question in your mind right away, like it's too late for a drill?
你当时脑子里马上就有疑问了吗，比如这太晚了，不像是演习？
Yes.
是的。
Which brings us to the day of the shooting. At 2:20 in the afternoon on Valentine's Day, a former student with an AR-15 began down the hallway of the first floor of the building that everyone calls the freshmen building. In an adjacent building, Ashley's culinary class had just finished their shrimp scampi lab. They were plating and cleaning up.
这就引出了枪击发生的当天。在情人节下午2点20分，一名持AR-15步枪的前学生开始沿着大家都称为“新生楼”的一楼走廊走去。在隔壁大楼，阿什利的烹饪课刚刚结束了虾仁意面实验。他们正在摆盘和清理。
I'm standing next to my door, pulling my doorstop out. I hear two pops. It was not rapid fire. It was just like a pop, pop. I'm not startled by it, because, I mean, it's Valentine's Day. And you don't know if it's, like, a balloon popping or what. And then the fire alarm went off very quickly.
我当时站在门边，正拔出我的门挡。我听到两声砰响。那不是连发。就像砰、砰。我没有被吓到，因为，我是说，那天是情人节。你不知道那是不是像气球爆炸之类的。然后火警很快响了起来。
The fire alarm. Dust set it off, dust from acoustical tiles hit by a round of gunshots. No one knew that at the time. Melissa, in a building farther out than Ashley's, didn't hear any pops, just a fire alarm. She went into action running that drill, the fire drill.
火警。粉尘引发了火警，圆弹射中声学天花板产生的粉尘。当时没人知道这一点。梅丽莎在离阿什利更远的一栋楼里，没有听到任何砰响，只听到了火警。她立即采取行动，进行了那次演习，火灾演习。
The fire alarm goes off, and I counted the kids as they left the room. I was the last one to leave. I closed the door. It was already locked because I leave it locked. Out the door with my phone, my keys, and my folder. Those are like the three most important things-- my phone, my keys, and my folder.
火警响了，我在学生离开房间时数了人数。我是最后一个离开的。我关上了门。它本来就是锁着的，因为我一直锁着。我带着手机、钥匙和文件夹走出门外。那些就像最重要的三样东西——我的手机、我的钥匙和我的文件夹。
Her emergency folder. That's the training.
她的应急文件夹。那就是培训的内容。
I went out the doors. The security person who's posted outside my hallway, she's there. And I said, oh, what's going on? Because they have walkie talkies. I don't. The security personnel have walkie talkies. So she said, someone set off a firecracker in the 1200 building. And I said, OK. And I turned to two other teachers and I told them.
我走出门外。负责我走廊的安保人员站在那里。我说，哦，怎么了？因为他们有对讲机。我没有。安保人员有对讲机。她说，有人在1200号教学楼放了鞭炮。我说，好的。然后我转身对另外两名老师说了。
And then as soon as I finished saying that to them, she yelled out, no, go back. It's a code red. Go back. It's a code red. And so we called to the kids, and I turned around and went back to my room, which was right there, opened up the door, and kids start streaming in.
就在我说完的那一刻，她大喊：不，回去。这是红色代码。回去。这是红色代码。于是我们大喊着让孩子们回去，我转身回到我的房间，就在那，打开门，孩子们开始涌入。
But was this a real code red? Melissa didn't know. She knew a fire alarm could go off during a code red, but the whole thing was confusing.
但这真的是红色代码吗？梅丽莎不知道。她知道红色代码期间火警可能会响起，但整个事情让人困惑。
Well, it was weird because we'd actually had an actual fire drill earlier in the day, like our planned, scheduled, monthly drill had occurred that morning. So it was weird that it was going off again because they don't do them in the last period of the day. And so I knew it was something, but I didn't think it was a serious something. I thought it was like-- the culinary was cooking with oil that day. So who knows.
嗯，这很奇怪，因为那天早些时候我们确实进行了一次真正的火灾演习，我们计划好的、定期的月度演习那天早上已经进行过了。所以它再次响起很奇怪，因为他们不会在最后一节课进行这种演习。所以我知道有些不对劲，但我不觉得那是严重的。我以为是像——烹饪课那天在用油做饭。所以谁知道呢。
Because that will sometimes set off the fire drill.
因为那有时会引发火警。
Of course will set it off if they burn something or whatever, so.
当然，如果他们烧坏了什么东西或之类的，肯定会引发。
Are there other things that set a fire drill? Oh, well, kids sometimes probably pull it.
还有其他东西会引发火警吗？哦，嗯，孩子们可能有时会拉响。
Yeah, sometimes kids will pull it. Sometimes there could be a faulty-- that's why our system gets inspected all the time. It just depends. But most-- I don't want to say mostly it's culinary, because Ashley Kurth will kill me, but a lot of times it's culinary. One time we went outside three times in one day because of the culinary class-- three times.
是的，有时孩子会拉响。有时可能是故障——这就是为什么我们的系统一直被检查。这只是看情况。但是大多——我不想说主要是因为烹饪课，因为阿什利·库斯会杀了我的，但很多时候确实是因为烹饪课。有一次我们因为烹饪课在一天内跑出去三次——三次。
Yeah. I mean, we have three smoke detectors in my room. So if you walk underneath it with a pot of boiling water, you will set the fire alarm off. That's kind of like the joke of our school.
是啊。我是说，我的房间里有三个烟雾探测器。所以如果你拿着一锅开水在下面走，你就会触发火警。这在我们学校里算是个笑话。
Teachers at Douglas knew that code red trumps a fire drill. They even had a plan for how to straighten that confusion out-- make an announcement, clarify the code red. On that day, an assistant principal, Mr. Porter, did that.
道格拉斯的老师们知道红色代码胜过火灾演习。他们甚至有一个计划来理清混乱——进行广播，澄清红色代码。那天，一位副校长波特先生确实这么做了。
Was there an announcement?
有公告吗？
There was, but a lot of people were already out of their room, so they didn't hear it.
有的，但很多人已经离开了房间，所以他们没听到。
In culinary, Ashley heard the code red. She's not sure about it, but she's going through the motions. She goes to her door to pull it shut. And as she does--
在烹饪课上，阿什利听到了红色代码。她不确定是不是真的，但她还是照做了。她走到门口关上门。就在她这么做的时候——
Two boys come running around the corner, and they're-- just they look terrified, and they're screaming, it's a shooter, it's a shooter.
两个男孩跑过拐角，他们——看起来非常惊恐，尖叫着：是枪手，是枪手。
She pulls them into her classroom, tells them to get in the storage closet with her students. But she's still thinking drill, right? It must be. It must be for practice. Even seconds later, when she hears--
她把他们拉进教室，让他们和她的学生一起躲进储藏室。但她心里还在想这是演习，对吧？一定是。这一定是练习。即使几秒钟后，当她听到——
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop. And to me, I'm like, OK, that's not what I experienced in the first drill just because of the rapid succession that was happening. At the time, I was like, maybe they're uppin' their game on that.
砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰，砰。对我来说，我心想，好的，这和我第一次演习时的体验不同，仅仅是因为那一连串紧凑的枪声。当时我心想，也许他们在这个演习上加大了难度。
It's unclear how many teachers thought like Ashley and Melissa did, that this was not a real code red, but the promised code red drill, and if this cost anyone their life. I spoke to the Broward County chief of staff in charge of organizing the district's safety upgrades where Douglas is. He said he didn't know any teachers at Douglas came out of that training expecting an unannounced drill with blanks. But eight of 14 teachers I spoke to said they were anticipating what Melissa and Ashley were, a surprise active shooter drill using blanks.
不清楚有多少老师像阿什利和梅丽莎那样，认为这并不是真正的红色代码，而是预期的红色代码演习，以及这是否导致了任何人丧命。我采访了负责组织该学区安全升级工作的布劳沃德县参谋长，道格拉斯高中就在该学区。他说他不知道道格拉斯的任何老师在培训后会期待这种带空包弹的突击演习。但在我采访的14名老师中，有8名表示他们预想到的正是梅丽莎和阿什利所期待的那种带空包弹的突击演习。
After those two boys tore around the corner yelling, it's a shooter, it's a shooter, Ashley stood for another second in her doorway, still confused. Then she glanced to her left all the way down the hall to a set of open doors, the face of the freshmen building.
在那两个男孩大喊着“是枪手，是枪手”跑过拐角后，阿什利在门口又站了一秒钟，仍然很困惑。然后她瞥了一眼左侧，一直看向走廊尽头的一组敞开的门，那是新生楼的正面。
I see like, hundreds of kids running out of the freshmen building looking terrified. When you see terrified kids running like that and they're not-- there is no rhyme or reason. It was chaos. And then you hear-- you can hear the gunshots. And it's just-- that is not what the drill was.
我看到成百上千个孩子从新生楼跑出来，看起来非常惊恐。当你看到惊恐的孩子那样跑，而且他们不是——那没有任何逻辑或缘由。那简直是混乱。然后你听到——你可以听到枪声。而且它只是——那根本不是演习。
She knew it was real.
她知道那是真的。
For like the next 90 seconds, as kids are running by me, I'm just screaming at them, keep running. Don't stop.
在那之后的90秒里，当孩子们从我身边跑过时，我只是对着他们尖叫：继续跑。不要停。
She shouted back to her kids, stay put and get down. She's still in her doorway when she realized there's another group, a smaller group.
她对自己的孩子喊道：待在原地，趴下。她仍然站在门口，这时她意识到还有另一群人，一群较小的人。
Kids that are running towards the freshmen building.
孩子们正朝着新生楼跑去。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yes. I was grabbing them and just pulling them into my room.
是的。我抓着他们，把他们拉进我的房间。
They were following instructions. Remember, if you're not in a classroom, run. Keep running away from the sound.
他们是在按照指示行动。记住，如果你不在教室里，跑。一直跑，远离声音来源。
How is it that kids are running towards kids running the other way?
为什么孩子们会朝着反方向奔跑的孩子们跑去？
Because the way that the gunshot sounds were ricocheting off the media center area, the quad, it sounded like there was shooting coming from that direction as well, which is why kids were running in the opposite direction.
因为枪声从媒体中心区域、方庭反射回来的方式，听起来就像枪声也从那个方向传来，这就是为什么孩子们会朝着相反的方向跑。
Wow.
哇。
To give you an idea, I had 29 students that were present that day with myself. And by the time we were finished, there were 65 total bodies in my room.
给你个概念，那天有29名学生和我在场。等我们结束后，房间里总共有65个人。
Wasn't the drill to shut the door and not let people in?
演习不是要把门关上，不让别人进来吗？
Yes, it was. [LAUGHING] Yes, it was.
是的，确实是。[笑声] 是的，确实是。
Then what happened?
那后来发生了什么？
There were terrified people running and I just-- I could not, in all consciousness, leave them be like that.
外面有惊恐的人在跑，我只是——无论如何，我良心上过不去，无法让他们那样待在外面。
Ashley wasn't the only teacher to stand in the doorway and say to hell with what she had been taught. You can choose to follow the protocol or follow your instinct. For some teachers, it wasn't a choice at all.
阿什利并不是唯一一个站在门口，对自己所受的训练说“见鬼去吧”的老师。你可以选择遵循协议，或者遵循本能。对一些老师来说，这根本不是选择。
In her classroom, Melissa got her attendance sheet out of her emergency folder. She counted 17 of her 25 students, and two from a different class she'd pulled in from the hallway. The group was small enough to fit in a supply closet, so Melissa told them to leave their backpacks out of sight, as she'd been taught, and move there. In the closet, it was hot and dark, except students' faces lit by their cell phones. Melissa had her phone out too.
在她的教室里，梅丽莎从应急文件夹中拿出了考勤表。她数了数，25名学生中来了17人，还有两个是从走廊里拉进来的其他班级的学生。这群人人数较少，能塞进储藏室，所以梅丽莎告诉他们按她学到的那样，把背包藏起来，然后躲进去。在储藏室里，既热又暗，只有孩子们手机照亮的脸。梅丽莎也拿出了手机。
There's a group text between me and three other teachers in the English department because we're friends outside of school. And my friend Stacey, who is on the third floor of the freshman building, she texts-- she sent a text to us that says, there is a shooter. There's a shooter in my floor.
我和英语系的另外三位老师之间有一个群聊，因为我们私下是朋友。我的朋友史黛西，在新生楼三楼，她发了短信——她发了一条短信说：有枪手。我这一层有枪手。
And so my friend Sarah says, drill or actual? And she says, actual, my window is blown out. And then she told us she had been grazed by a bullet. She was grazed in her arm by a bullet.
于是我的朋友莎拉说：是演习还是真的？她说：真的，我的窗户被打碎了。然后她告诉我们她被子弹擦伤了。她的手臂被子弹擦伤了。
Oh, my god.
天哪。
And I didn't hear from her for a while.
后来我好一会儿没收到她的消息。
An hour went by.
过了一个小时。
We heard noises in the hallway. We got really quiet. I had the flashlight part of my phone on so that we could kind of like illuminate the closet without having the light on. And when I heard the door open-- but it sounded like it was opened with a key. And so then I could hear movement in the room. And then somebody--
我们听到走廊里有动静。我们变得非常安静。我打开了手机的手电筒，这样我们可以在不开大灯的情况下照亮储藏室。当我听到门打开时——听起来像是用钥匙打开的。然后我能听到房间里的动静。接着有人——
And that's comforting or not?
那让你感到安慰还是不安？
I mean, not, because you don't know what the hell is happening. And the police-- and then the police officer said, this is the police. Is anyone in here? And then there was kind of like a pause. And then they're like, this is the police. Is anyone in here? And I was like, guys, I'm going to open the door because--
我是说，不安，因为你根本不知道发生了什么鬼事。警察——然后警察说：这是警察。这里有人吗？然后有一阵停顿。他们又说：这是警察。这里有人吗？我对孩子们说：伙计们，我要开门，因为——
Someone says, this is the police, is anyone in here? And your first thought is, it really is the police, or still you're not sure?
有人说“这是警察，这里有人吗”，你的第一反应是真的警察，还是仍然不确定？
I'm still not sure. The first time they said it, I'm not sure what I should do. Am I supposed to open the door?
我仍然不确定。他们第一次说的时候，我不确定我该做什么。我是不是应该开门？
They didn't cover that in training.
培训中没提过这个。
Very slowly, the handle, and I opened it really slow because even if it is the police, they have weapons too, and they're looking for the shooter. So I know they have their weapons drawn.
非常缓慢地，握住把手，我打开得非常慢，因为即使是警察，他们也带着武器，他们也在寻找枪手。所以我知道他们是拔着枪的。
She really just had to guess about whether to trust this was a cop and not a group of shooters saying they were cops.
她实际上只能猜测该不该相信这是警察，而不是一群谎称是警察的枪手。
And so I just very slowly opened, pulled on the handle, pushed it open and said, we're in here. We're in the closet. And then they started giving us instructions. Come out with your hands up.
所以我只是非常缓慢地打开，拉动把手，推开门说：我们在这儿。我们在储藏室里。然后他们开始给我们指示：举起手出来。
Melissa told me that Ashley was one of five people she knew who had broken protocol that day, by holding their doors open longer than they were supposed to.
梅丽莎告诉我，阿什利是她知道那天打破协议的五个人之一，通过比规定时间更久地敞开门。
And they even did that on the third floor when they knew something was wrong. And my friend Stacey held her door open until she was like, locked eyes with the shooter, and yells to Scott Beigel to close his door, and grabs the handle with two hands and pulls it closed. So her door was open up to the moment he started, like, shooting bullets down the hallway.
他们在三楼也是这么做的，当时他们知道出事了。我的朋友史黛西一直敞开门，直到她和枪手对视，对斯科特·贝格尔大喊让他关上门，然后用双手抓住把手拉上门。所以她的门一直开到他开始向走廊射击的那一刻。
Stacey is the teacher whose arm was grazed. She survived. Scott Beigel in the room next to Stacey's did the same thing Stacey did, waited a little with the door open. He's one of the 17 who died that day, standing in his doorway.
史黛西就是那位手臂被擦伤的老师。她活下来了。隔壁房间的斯科特·贝格尔做了和史黛西一样的事，开着门等了一会儿。他是那天死亡的17人之一，当时就站在门口。
There's very little evidence about whether school shooting drills of any kind actually work. The data doesn't exist. School shootings, for how much we think and talk about them, are still statistically rare. But now, Melissa and Ashley have been in that rare situation, the one that's hard to study.
几乎没有证据表明任何类型的校园枪击演习真的有效。数据不存在。考虑到我们思考和谈论它们的程度，校园枪击事件在统计学上仍然很少见。但现在，梅丽莎和阿什利已经身处那种罕见的情况，那种难以研究的情况。
And they both told me that having a playbook for what to do helped. Now I lock my door. Now I count the kids in my class. Now I move us all to a closet. But they also both had ideas coming out of this, about ways they could have been better prepared. Melissa, for instance, wanted trauma kits with gauze in every classroom and training on how to treat bullet wounds with it. Gauze actually has saved lives in mass shootings.
她们都告诉我，有一个应对方案确实有帮助。现在我锁门。现在我清点班里的孩子。现在我把大家都转移到储藏室。但她们在经历这一切后也都有了想法，关于如何能做得更好。例如，梅丽莎想要每个教室都有装有纱布的创伤包，并接受如何用它处理枪伤的培训。在群体枪击事件中，纱布确实挽救了生命。
I really wanted to find some expert to weigh in on Douglas, to tell me, did the teachers' training help? Did more kids survive because of it? What might have worked better?
我真的很想找一位专家来评估道格拉斯的情况，告诉我老师的培训是否有帮助？更多的孩子是因为它而活下来的吗？什么方法可能会更好？
Cheryl Jonson researches what's effective in these drills at Xavier University and is a training instructor for ALICE, one of two big companies in the US that train schools how to respond to active shooters. ALICE has its own way of doing things, just like the other big outfit, Safe Havens International, has its own way of doing things. There's no one single way, no agreement on what's best.
谢丽尔·琼森在泽维尔大学研究这些演习的有效性，并且是ALICE的培训讲师，这是美国培训学校如何应对活跃枪手的两大机构之一。ALICE有自己的工作方式，就像另一个大机构“安全港国际”有自己的一套。没有单一的方法，也没有关于什么是最好的共识。
Cheryl Jonson didn't want to get into the specifics of what happened at Douglas, partly because it's still too soon. The investigation isn't done. But she did talk to me more generally about some of things I knew they'd done at Douglas, like papering over windows. Cheryl doesn't think it helps much.
谢丽尔·琼森不想深入探讨道格拉斯发生的具体细节，部分原因是因为时间还太短。调查还没有完成。但她确实更笼统地和我谈了一些我知道他们在道格拉斯做过的事情，比如在窗户上贴纸。谢丽尔认为这没什么帮助。
It's 2 o'clock on a Tuesday. The shooter knows you're in your classrooms.
现在是周二下午2点。枪手知道你在教室里。
Also, code red, all the codes, their colors and meanings. The consultants I talked to said no to this too.
还有红色代码，所有的代码，它们的颜色和含义。我采访的顾问也否定了这一点。
I'm a big advocate for not using codes at all.
我强烈主张完全不要使用代码。
How come?
为什么？
If I say "code red," it takes a split second for your brain to go, OK, code red means bad, means active shooter, means I have to do this versus if I say there is a gunman in the school.
如果我说“红色代码”，你的大脑需要分裂一秒钟去理解：好的，红色代码意味着坏事，意味着活跃枪手，意味着我必须这样做。而如果我说：学校里有持枪歹徒。
Keeping classroom doors locked, resounding yes. But the idea that this is all you do, that you lock the door and put every kid under a desk, all the consultants I talked to said that's outdated. Cheryl says people need many more options, many more ways to respond to a shooting.
保持教室门锁闭，绝对赞成。但认为这就是全部，你锁上门，让每个孩子钻进书桌底下，我采访的所有顾问都说这过时了。谢丽尔说人们需要更多的选择，更多应对枪击的方式。
Sometimes you stay in your room. Sometimes you evacuate, like if you're far enough away from the shooter or in an open space with more exits, like a cafeteria or a gym. As a last resort, you fight. Basically, trust your ability to make a decision.
有时你待在房间里。有时你撤离，比如如果你离枪手足够远，或者在有更多出口的开放空间，比如食堂或健身房。作为最后手段，你反击。基本上，相信你做决定的能力。
I told her about Ashley Kurth, how she had stood in her doorway, grabbing up dozens of scared students. Remember, it was a break from her school's protocol. Cheryl's such an advocate for thinking on your feet. I wondered if she maybe believed Ashley did the right thing, pulling in kids.
我告诉她阿什利·库斯的事，她如何在门口站着，拉进几十个受惊的学生。记住，这打破了她学校的规矩。谢丽尔非常主张临场发挥。我怀疑她是否认为阿什利可能做的是正确的事。
The problem with this-- unless you're there, you don't know what exactly happened. Now, did she probably save lives? Probably. And in that situation, did it work with the gunman being in a different building? Yes.
这件事的问题在于——除非你在场，否则你不知道究竟发生了什么。现在，她可能挽救了生命吗？可能。在那种情况下，枪手在另一栋楼里，这有效吗？是的。
One thing that was part of the training at Douglas was barricading your door, basically pushing lots of furniture up against your classroom door. But Melissa and Ashley didn't do it. Seems like very few teachers did. Though if Ashley had done it, if she'd followed the protocol, locked and barricaded her door right away, it would've been way harder to pull all those kids into her room from the hallway. She'd have to unbarricade herself first. Fewer kids would have made it in.
道格拉斯培训的一部分是封锁门，基本上就是把很多家具堆在教室门前。但梅丽莎和阿什利没有这样做。似乎很少有老师这样做。尽管如果阿什利这样做了，如果她遵循规矩，锁上门并立即封锁，那么从走廊里把所有那些孩子拉进她的房间就会困难得多。她必须先解开门。能进来的孩子会少得多。
Reporting on this for several months, I knew what I was looking for, something concrete to tell my daughter's school. My daughter's nine, fourth grade. Last year, she did a traditional lockdown at her school, squat and hide. But when I asked her what the drill was for, she said, I don't know exactly. They didn't say. It's not great.
关于这个课题报道了几个月，我知道我在寻找什么，一些具体的建议告诉我女儿的学校。我女儿九岁，四年级。去年，她在学校进行了传统的封锁，蹲下隐藏。但当我问她演习是为了什么时，她说：我不确切知道。他们没说。这不太好。
I keep thinking about this one shooting, the Red Lake Indian Reservation shooting, and how in that one, a classroom of students did a traditional lockdown, squat and hide, because they practiced it, and how an investigator on that case told me that drill did not help them at all. They'd have been better off without it. And the researcher who told me we should not do drills in school, period. It's too traumatizing for kids. We don't pretend to crash on an airplane. We just deal with the possibility of crashing by hearing some instructions.
我一直想起一次枪击案，红湖印第安保留地枪击案，在那次事件中，一教室的学生进行了传统的封锁，蹲下隐藏，因为他们练习过，而那个案件的一名调查员告诉我，演习对他们根本没有帮助。没有它他们会更好。还有研究人员告诉我们根本不应该在学校进行演习。这对孩子太有创伤了。我们不会假装飞机坠毁。我们通过听一些指令来处理坠毁的可能性。
Where I come down on this-- I don't agree with no drills at all. I want my daughter to know everything. I want her to know about barricading, and I want her to know about running and fighting back. I want her to know about active shooters because it's a thing to reckon with. I want her to know there's nothing that can keep her completely safe because it's the truth.
关于这一点我的结论是——我不同意完全不进行演习。我希望我女儿知道一切。我希望她知道封锁，我希望她知道奔跑和反击。我希望她知道活跃枪手，因为这是需要面对的事情。我希望她知道没有什么能让她完全安全，因为这就是事实。
One more thing I'd say to my daughter's school, Cheryl's point about don't say codes. Call it like it is. I don't want someone to come over an intercom and tell my daughter code red. I want someone to say, listen up, there's a person with a gun in our school. Of course, I never want someone to say that at all.
我还要对女儿学校说的另一件事，谢丽尔关于不要使用代码的观点。照实说。我不希望有人通过对讲机告诉我女儿红色代码。我希望有人说：听着，学校里有一个带枪的人。当然，我根本不希望任何人这么说。
This year at Douglas, there are new gates, new fences, new cameras, gym bag searches, key card entry for staff, gauze-filled trauma kits in every room, 15 campus monitors compared to five last year, three school resource officers instead of one. And they already did a code red drill, only this time there was no confusion about when it would be. The school called parents, told all the students and teachers in advance. When it started, the principal came on the PA and told everyone, OK, here we go. And this is our code red. And try to breathe. Keep breathing.
今年在道格拉斯，有新的大门、新的围栏、新的摄像头、健身包检查、教职员工门禁卡、每个房间都有装有纱布的创伤包，15名校园监控人员（去年只有5名），3名学校资源官员（取代了原来的1名）。他们已经进行了一次红色代码演习，只是这一次关于演习时间没有任何困惑。学校提前通知了家长，告诉了所有学生和老师。演习开始时，校长在广播里告诉大家：好的，开始了。这就是我们的红色代码。试着呼吸。继续呼吸。
Only real surprise since school started, if you can call it that, the fire alarm. It's gone off seven times so far this year-- malfunctions, maintenance, a special ed kid pulled it twice. Two times it happened right before school got out. Melissa said the first time it happened a week in, she cursed. Students cried.
开学以来唯一的真正的意外，如果能这么称呼的话，就是火警。今年到目前为止响了七次——故障、维护、一个特殊教育部的孩子拉了两次。有两次发生在放学前。梅丽莎说第一次发生在开学一周时，她骂了人。学生们哭了。
One student, Julia, froze. Julia, Melissa said, you're OK. Am I? Julia said.
一个叫朱莉娅的学生惊呆了。梅丽莎说：朱莉娅，你没事的。我是吗？朱莉娅说。
What the school does not do during the fire alarms, evacuate, like they're supposed to. No one goes outside to the parking lot. No one jokes about culinary. No one moves. Not a single class evacuates.
学校在火警期间没有做的是撤离，尽管他们本应该这样做。没人去停车场。没人开烹饪课的玩笑。没人动。没有一个班级撤离。
Melissa says it's too scary to be out there standing in the parking lot like that, vulnerable. What if there's a sniper? It's what they know now. Drills have blind spots.
梅丽莎说，站在停车场那样的环境下太可怕了，太脆弱了。如果有个狙击手怎么办？这就是他们现在知道的。演习有盲点。
Robyn Semien is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, a couple returns to the worst thing that ever happened to them, over and over again. Why? In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
罗宾·塞米恩是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，一对夫妇一遍又一遍地回到他们发生过的最糟糕的事情中。为什么？一会儿后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Before the Next One." Now the mass shootings have become the new normal in our country. We have stories of people preparing for the next one in various ways. We've arrived at act two of our program, act two. Keep breathing.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目，“在下一次之前”。现在群体枪击事件已经成为我国的新常态。我们有关于人们以各种方式为下一次做准备的故事。我们已经进入了节目的第二部分，第二部分。继续呼吸。
So there's a whole infrastructure that springs into action every time a mass shooting occurs. There's Red Cross, fire and police departments, SWAT teams, therapy dogs, the Billy Graham prayer truck. But now, there's also a group of people who show up in the immediate aftermath for more personal reasons. These are the parents of kids who've died in other mass shootings.
所以每次发生群体枪击事件时，就会有一整套基础设施投入运作。有红十字会、消防和警察部门、特警队、治疗犬、比利·格雷厄姆祈祷卡车。但现在，还有一群人因为更个人的原因出现在随后的直接后果中。这些人是在其他群体枪击事件中失去孩子的父母。
And what they do at these shootings is so simple and kind of amazing to hear. Producer Miki Meek talked with two of these parents. It's a couple named Sandy and Lonnie Phillips. Their daughter, Jessi, died when a gunman opened fire in a movie theater in Aurora, Colorado back in 2012. And since then, they have organized their lives to be able to reach out to other parents like themselves. Here's Miki.
他们在这些枪击事件中所做的非常简单，听起来非常令人惊叹。制片人米基·米克与其中的两位父母进行了交谈。这是一对名叫桑迪和朗尼·菲利普斯的夫妇。他们的女儿杰西在2012年科罗拉多州奥罗拉的一家电影院里遭遇枪手开火时不幸身亡。从那时起，他们就安排了自己的生活，以便能够接触到像他们一样的其他父母。这是米基。
Sandy and Lonnie Phillips have traveled to eight mass shootings since Aurora. It started with Sandy Hook and Isla Vista, San Bernardino, Orlando, Las Vegas, Sutherland Springs, Parkland, and then Santa Fe, Texas, which is where I met up with them in May, right after a student walked into the high school and killed 10 people. They pulled up in front of the school in their truck. Even though they have done this a lot, Sandy told me the discomfort and awkwardness they feel about showing up like this in a community has never gone away.
自奥罗拉事件以来，桑迪和朗尼·菲利普斯已经去了八次群体枪击事件现场。从桑迪胡克开始，还有伊斯拉维斯塔、圣贝纳迪诺、奥兰多、拉斯维加斯、萨瑟兰斯普林斯、帕克兰，然后是德克萨斯州的圣达菲，我在五月份在那里见到了他们，就在一名学生走进高中杀害10人之后。他们把卡车停在学校前面。尽管他们这样做过很多次，桑迪告诉我，他们在这种社区中露面时感受到的不适和尴尬从未消失。
Ready for this?
准备好了吗？
But in Santa Fe, they just launched themselves in anyway. They're each wearing a big button with a photo of their daughter, Jessi, smiling. A memorial had just gone up on a big, grassy lawn out front. There were 10 wood crosses, each with a red heart and a photo of the student or teacher who had been killed. People were starting to leave teddy bears, flowers, and balloons.
但在圣达菲，他们还是直接进去了。他们每个人都戴着一个大纽扣，上面印着他们女儿杰西微笑的照片。前方的大草坪上刚刚竖起了一个纪念碑。有10个木十字架，每个都有一个红色的心，以及被杀害的学生或老师的照片。人们开始放置泰迪熊、鲜花和气球。
What the Phillips do here is just talk to whoever wants to talk. They figure that'll lead them to families they might be useful to. And within seconds of getting out of their truck, they bump into a dazed teenage girl wearing shorts and a Santa Fe High School soccer T-shirt.
菲利普斯在这里所做的是和任何想交谈的人交谈。他们觉得这会把他们引向他们可能有用的家庭。在他们下车几秒钟内，他们就遇到了一个神情恍惚的十几岁女孩，穿着短裤和圣达菲高中足球T恤。
Excuse me, how are you doing?
打扰一下，你好吗？
I'm not OK.
我不好。
And here, the sound gets muffled because Sandy's tiny mic gets crushed when they hug. It's the main sound I remember from that day.
在这里，声音变得模糊了，因为桑迪的微型麦克风在他们拥抱时被压碎了。那是我那天记忆最深的声音。
[TAPPING ON MIC]
[敲击麦克风的声音]
We're just so sorry this has happened to you and your friends and your families and your community.
我们非常抱歉这发生在你和你的朋友、家人以及社区身上。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
Another girl, a junior with light brown hair pulled back into a ponytail, walks up to them and stares at their buttons.
另一个女孩，扎着马尾辫、浅棕色头发的大三学生，走到他们面前，盯着他们的纽扣。
We lost our daughter in a mass shooting six years ago.
六年前我们在一次群体枪击事件中失去了女儿。
Is that her?
那是她吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
She's pretty.
她很漂亮。
Thank you. She is. Inside and out, she was lovely, just like your friends.
谢谢。她是。由内而外，她都很可爱，就像你的朋友们一样。
Sandy is good at making people feel comfortable. She has a round, warm face, framed by a gray bob. She's maternal and keeps her comments caring and brief.
桑迪很擅长让人们感到舒适。她有一张圆润、温暖的脸，留着灰色的波波头。她很有母性，评论既关怀又简短。
Lonnie stands right next to Sandy with his arm around her. Sandy's the one who mostly talks to the kids, but he's always by her side, listening intently. His presence helps her do this. He looks out for her, sometimes running ahead to start the AC in their truck before she climbs in.
朗尼站在桑迪旁边，搂着她。桑迪主要是和孩子们交谈，但他总是陪在她身边，专注地听着。他的存在帮助她做这件事。他照顾她，有时在钻进卡车之前先跑去启动AC。
Hi.
你好。
My name's Tracy.
我叫特雷西。
Hi, Tracy.
你好，特雷西。
I hear you had a daughter--
我听说你们有个女儿——
I was surprised at how quickly people opened up to the Phillipses.
我很惊讶人们如此迅速地向菲利普斯敞开心扉。
Jessi.
杰西。
Jessi? Beautiful.
杰西？很美。
The girl who said Jessi was pretty, she started telling them that she escaped the shooting by hiding behind a building with other students. Now, she just wanted to stay at home. But at home, all she could think about was the shooting. Scenes from that day kept replaying through her head. Sandy doesn't miss a beat here.
说杰西很漂亮的那个女孩，开始告诉他们，她通过躲在建筑后面和其他学生一起逃离了枪击。现在，她只想待在家里。但在家里，她脑子里想的都是枪击。那天的场景在她的脑海里不断重播。桑迪在这里一点也没错过。
Over at the victims' assistance, they have trauma therapists over there. I recommend strongly that any of you kids, really think about stopping by the victims' assistance.
在受害者援助中心，他们有创伤治疗师。我强烈建议你们这些孩子中的任何一个，真的考虑一下去受害者援助中心看看。
I will.
我会的。
Do some trauma therapy. OK, honey.
做一些创伤治疗。好的，亲爱的。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
You're welcome.
不客气。
The Phillipses don't make money off this. They're volunteers, and they're not wealthy either. They're retirees living in a 245-square foot trailer, surviving off of modest savings and social security. Sandy is 68 and used to work in tourism for the city of San Antonio. And Lonnie is 74. He used to own some car lots.
菲利普斯并没有从中获利。他们是志愿者，也不富有。他们是退休人员，住在一个245平方英尺的拖车里，靠微薄的储蓄和社会保障金生活。桑迪68岁，以前在圣安东尼奥市从事旅游业。朗尼74岁。他以前拥有一些停车场。
So have you guys met?
所以你们见过面了吗？
Yes.
是的。
One thing I quickly realized going to Santa Fe is that there are now so many of these mass shootings that they become grim reunions for all the people who show up to them as part of their jobs or volunteer work.
去圣达菲我很快意识到的一件事是，现在有太多的这种群体枪击事件，以至于它们成为了所有以工作或志愿服务身份出现的人的阴郁重聚。
Are you from Las Vegas?
你是来自拉斯维加斯吗？
Sandy and Lonnie ran into an emergency responder from the Las Vegas shooting, and then bumped into this other guy who travels around, putting up all those white crosses you see at almost every mass shooting. He made one for their daughter, Jessi, in Aurora too. Standing on the patchy brown grass next to the crosses, Lonnie interrupted him to do this thing he and Sandy do a lot.
桑迪和朗尼遇到了拉斯维加斯枪击案的一名紧急救援人员，然后碰到了另一个到处走动、在几乎每起群体枪击事件中竖起那些白色十字架的家伙。他也为他们在奥罗拉的女儿杰西做了一个。站在十字架旁边的斑驳棕色草地上，朗尼打断了他，做了他和桑迪经常做的这件事。
Sign, 1:11.
标记，1:11。
They suddenly call out the time.
他们突然大声说出时间。
We have a 1:11, 11:11, and we're talking to you at 1:11. So it's a sign from our daughter.
我们有1:11，11:11，我们正和你在1:11交谈。所以这是我们女儿的迹象。
11:11 is a thing. A lot of people see it as an auspicious sign or a time to make a wish. And it was a lyric in one of Jessi's favorite songs.
11:11是一件事。很多人认为这是一个吉利的迹象，或者是一个许愿的时间。那是杰西最喜欢的歌之一的歌词。
If we get 11:11 twice a day, we know we really had a good day.
如果我们每天两次得到11:11，我们知道我们真的过了美好的一天。
They told me, I know it's silly, but I take it as a hello or a god wink. It helps.
他们告诉我，我知道这很傻，但我把它当作一个问候或者上帝的眨眼。它有帮助。
Hello. What's your name?
你好。你叫什么名字？
Cindy Evans.
辛迪·埃文斯。
Cindy, Cindy?
辛迪，辛迪？
My son is in high school here.
我儿子在这所高中上学。
Oh, I'm so sorry.
哦，我很抱歉。
As the day went on, people kept dropping by the memorial in front of the high school. Parents and students stood huddled together, staring at the crosses or writing messages on them. It was quiet and hot and still. There was a low generator hum from the gigantic Billy Graham ministry truck set up in the parking lot. And then all of a sudden, this young guy started wailing. Sandy made a beeline for him.
随着一天的推移，人们不断来到高中前的纪念碑。家长和学生蜷缩在一起，盯着十字架或在上面写下留言。那里安静、炎热、静止。停车场设置的巨大的比利·格雷厄姆事工卡车发出低沉的发电机嗡嗡声。然后突然，这个年轻人开始嚎叫。桑迪径直向他走去。
It's too much, man. It's too dang much. I'm so angry.
这太多了，伙计。这太该死了。我很生气。
He immediately threw his arms around her.
他立刻用双臂搂住了她。
Why this thing keeps happening.
为什么这东西一直在发生。
Here, here, here, here. Put your arms around me.
这里，这里，这里，这里。把你的手搂着我。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
It's OK. It's OK.
没事的。没事的。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
It's not OK. It's not OK. Let it go, let it go, let it go, let it go. Just cry your heart out.
这不没事。这不没事。发泄出来，发泄出来，发泄出来，发泄出来。尽情哭出来吧。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
Cry your heart out and get your anger out on here, on here, on here.
尽情哭出来，把你的愤怒发泄在这里，在这里，在这里。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
I'm so sorry. Oh, god, I'm so sorry.
我很抱歉。哦，上帝，我很抱歉。
It makes me wish I could've done something.
这让我希望我本可以做点什么。
OK. It's OK, honey. You're doing it now.
好的。没事的，亲爱的。你现在正在做。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
You OK?
你没事吧？
He graduated last year. There were crosses set up for three people he knew well. One of them was a teacher named Ms. Perkins, who he really loved. He said she always tried to be strict with him but could never keep up that front for very long.
他去年毕业了。有三个他很熟悉的人的十字架。其中一位是名叫珀金斯女士的老师，他真的很爱她。他说她总是试图对他严厉，但从未能保持这种表情太久。
Just breathe. Take a nice, deep breath.
呼吸。深呼吸。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
Take a nice, deep breath.
深呼吸。
[SOBBING]
[啜泣]
OK, OK. Breathe with me. [EXHALING]
好的，好的。和我一起呼吸。[呼气]
Thank you.
谢谢。
There you go.
就这样。
After a few minutes, he's caught his breath enough to talk. He tells Sandy he wants the shootings to stop. He wants to take action somehow. And then he suddenly switches gears and starts spilling out his feelings about guns and gun control.
几分钟后，他喘过气来足以说话。他告诉桑迪他希望枪击停止。他希望以某种方式采取行动。然后他突然转变方向，开始倾诉他关于枪支和枪支管制的感受。
Nowadays with the violence that is going on in this world, taking guns away is not going to change that because it's just like drugs. They make drugs illegal and are still able to get drugs.
如今随着世界上发生的暴力，取消枪支并不能改变这一点，因为它就像毒品一样。他们让毒品非法，却仍然能够得到毒品。
He plans to get a concealed handgun license when he turns 21 later this year. The Phillipses are actually gun owners too. They have a 12-gauge shotgun. They believe in the Second Amendment. But they're also advocates for universal background checks and tight regulations on the types of guns, ammunition, and accessories, like bump stocks, a person can buy.
他计划在今年晚些时候21岁时获得隐藏式手枪许可证。菲利普斯实际上也是枪支拥有者。他们有一把12号口径霰弹枪。他们相信第二修正案。但他们也是全民背景调查和对枪支类型、弹药和配件（如撞火枪托）进行严格监管的倡导者。
However, Sandy says they don't push their political beliefs on survivors when they're doing outreach. Their primary goal is to support. But it's impossible for grieving parents to avoid the politics around guns. There's a whole movement of conspiracy theorists who believe that the US government stages mass shootings to make guns look bad.
然而，桑迪说，当他们进行外展活动时，他们不会向幸存者推销他们的政治信仰。他们的首要目标是支持。但悲伤的父母不可能避开关于枪支的政治。有一整群阴谋论者认为美国政府策划了群体枪击事件，使枪支看起来很糟糕。
We were told by Alex Jones that our daughter never existed.
亚历克斯·琼斯告诉我们，我们的女儿从未存在过。
Alex Jones, of course, is famous for saying that mass shootings are fake. He's now a defendant in several defamation lawsuits. When the Phillipses ran into him face-to-face at a gun control event, he accused them of inventing their entire story.
亚历克斯·琼斯当然以说群体枪击事件是假的而闻名。他现在是多起诽谤诉讼的被告。当菲利普斯在枪支管制活动中与他面对面时，他指责他们编造了整个故事。
And then two minutes later, he's saying, your daughter's still alive, and she's living in the Bahamas, and she's living the high life. And you're crisis actors, and you're paid by the Obama administration, and da da da. I'm listening to him, just going, you are so absolutely crazy.
然后两分钟后，他说，你的女儿还活着，她住在巴哈马，她过着奢华的生活。你们是危机演员，你们是被奥巴马政府付钱的，等等等等。我听着他，只是觉得：你绝对太疯狂了。
Lonnie got into it with Jones, stood right in front of him. It looked like a shoving match was about to start, until Sandy stepped in and broke it up. I reached out to Jones through one of his lawyers, who declined to comment. The conspiracy theorists, known as truthers or hoaxers, troll families of victims on social media immediately after any mass shooting.
朗尼和琼斯较上了劲，站在他面前。看起来一场推搡就要开始了，直到桑迪介入并将其打断。我通过他的一位律师联系了琼斯，该律师拒绝置评。这些阴谋论者，被称为“真相寻求者”或“骗局制造者”，在任何群体枪击事件发生后立即在社交媒体上骚扰受害者家庭。
This can get dangerous. After the Phillipses' son gave interviews in Aurora, he got death threats and had to get the FBI involved. The man who was threatening him ended up in jail. So hoaxers are one of the things the Phillips has warned parents about. They tell families to brace themselves.
这可能会变得危险。在菲利普斯的儿子在奥罗拉接受采访后，他受到了死亡威胁，不得不让联邦调查局介入。威胁他的人最终进了监狱。所以骗局制造者是菲利普斯警告父母的事情之一。他们告诉家庭做好心理准备。
After watching Lonnie and Sandy in Santa Fe, I wondered why in the world they were throwing themselves back into this setting, reliving their worst moment over and over again. The answer, of course, starts with their daughter's shooting. They got the news in the middle of the night when they were asleep at their home in Texas.
在圣达菲看了朗尼和桑迪之后，我纳闷为什么他们会把自己重新抛回这个环境中，一遍又一遍地重温他们最糟糕的时刻。答案当然从他们女儿的枪击开始。他们在深夜睡觉时在德克萨斯州的家中得到了这个消息。
This was back in 2012. And their daughter, Jessi, was in college at the time. She got to see the new Batman movie, The Dark Knight Rises, with one of her friends at a multiplex in Aurora, Colorado. About a half hour after the movie started, Jessi's friend called Sandy from the theater.
那是在2012年。他们的女儿杰西当时在上大学。她和她的一个朋友在科罗拉多州奥罗拉的一家多厅影院看了新的蝙蝠侠电影《黑暗骑士崛起》。电影开始半小时后，杰西的朋友从影院打电话给桑迪。
The minute I picked up the phone, there was screaming, just horrible screaming in the background, panic. And he said, there's been a shooting. And I was like, what is he talking about? Because Jessi had been at a mall in Toronto almost seven weeks before, where there was a mass shooting.
我接电话的那一刻，背景里有尖叫声，只是可怕的尖叫声，恐慌。他说，发生了枪击。我心想：他在说什么？因为杰西在近七周前曾在多伦多的一家购物中心，那里发生了群体枪击事件。
This was a coincidence. Jessi had left a food court in a mall just three minutes before a man walked in and opened fire.
这只是巧合。杰西在一个人走进并开火前三分钟离开了购物中心的美食广场。
So my first thought was, this isn't funny. But he's not a prankster. And I said, are you OK? And he said, I think I've been hit twice. And it was when he said that that I went, why isn't Jessi calling? And I knew something was really wrong. He said, I tried.
所以我的第一反应是：这不好笑。但他不是个恶作剧者。我说：你没事吧？他说：我想我被击中两次。正是他这么说的时候，我心想：为什么杰西不打电话？我知道一定出大事了。他说：我试过了。
And that's when I woke up because the scream was so loud. It was so horrific and something I never heard before.
就在那时我醒了，因为尖叫声太大了。它是如此恐怖，是我从未听过的。
Lonnie found Sandy in the living room, sliding down a wall. He picked her up and took her to their couch, where he held her. Jessi was one of 12 people killed that night. Another 70 people were injured. And then five months later, there was another mass shooting, Sandy Hook, where 20 first graders and six educators died.
朗尼在客厅发现了滑落墙面的桑迪。他把她扶起来带到沙发上，紧紧抱着她。杰西是那晚遇难的12人之一。另有70人受伤。五个月后，又发生了一起群体枪击事件，桑迪胡克小学，20名一年级学生和6名教育工作者死亡。
Days later, the Brady Campaign to prevent gun violence contacted the Phillipses. They were reaching out to families from other mass shootings and asked if they'd be willing to travel to Newtown to talk to parents there. Sandy says they didn't even have to think about it. They immediately said yes, because they wished they'd had someone to talk to right after Jessi died.
几天后，布雷迪防止枪支暴力运动联系了菲利普斯。他们联系了来自其他群体枪击事件的家庭，询问他们是否愿意去纽敦与那里的父母交谈。桑迪说他们甚至不需要思考。他们立即同意了，因为他们希望在杰西死后有人能和他们说话。
But when they arrived at a community center in Newtown, Sandy says they felt nervous and uncomfortable. Maybe they were intruding. They weren't sure if these parents would feel angry or grateful about their presence.
但当他们到达纽敦的一个社区中心时，桑迪说他们感到紧张和不适。也许他们在侵入。他们不确定这些父母会对他们的出现感到愤怒还是感激。
It's like walking into a funeral of people that you don't know. And I remember saying to my husband, when we walked in the room and I saw their faces, I said, that's what we looked like five months ago.
就像走进一个你不认识的人的葬礼。我记得我对我丈夫说，当我们走进房间看到他们的脸时，我说：那正是我们五个月前看起来的样子。
What does that look like?
那看起来是什么样的？
Pff. They're hanging on to each other. They've been crying, so their eyes are red. They're walking almost robot-like. Their bodies are moving, but they're not really there. I realized, that's what I looked like just five months ago. But it also made me realize, this is exactly what I want to be doing.
呼。他们紧紧抓住对方。他们一直在哭，所以眼睛是红的。他们走起路来像机器人。他们的身体在移动，但他们并没有真正在那里。我意识到：我五个月前看起来就是那样。但这也让我意识到：这正是我想要做的事情。
She wanted to help these parents acclimate to their new reality. Looking back, Sandy says it was probably too soon for them to be out there trying to comfort other parents when they were still so raw. But the Phillipses said there was also a strong and instant sense of kinship that they couldn't turn away from.
她想帮助这些父母适应他们的新现实。回过头来看，桑迪说，当他们还如此生疏时，他们可能太早就在外面试图安慰其他父母了。但菲利普斯说，也有一种强烈而即时的亲属感，他们无法转过身去。
While they were there, they ran into parents from other mass shootings, too, parents from Virginia Tech and Tucson. These parents had lost kids suddenly and violently in places where they thought that they were safe. The Phillipses now had parents that they could lean on too.
在那里，他们也遇到了来自其他群体枪击事件的父母，来自弗吉尼亚理工大学和图森的父母。这些父母突然且暴力地失去了孩子，在他们认为安全的地方。菲利普斯现在有了他们也可以依靠的父母。
This was the moment that launched the Phillipses into what's become their life work. They could see the need. There are no experts on what to do when your child dies in a mass shooting. The only experts are the people it's happened to.
这一刻启动了菲利普斯，变成了他们一生的工作。他们看到了需求。当你的孩子在群体枪击事件中死亡时，没有专家知道该做什么。唯一的专家是发生过这种情况的人。
So to help them find each other, Lonnie and Sandy have set up an organization called Survivors Empowered. They help families navigate their grief, plus a bunch of other practical things, everything from medical bills and charity scams that use kids' photos to raise money, to how to get your child's body home if you live out of state. However, this new mission was hard for their family and friends to comprehend.
为了帮助他们找到彼此，朗尼和桑迪成立了一个名为“幸存者赋权”的组织。他们帮助家庭应对悲伤，再加上许多其他实际的事情，从医疗费和利用孩子照片筹款的慈善骗局，到如果你不住在州内，如何把孩子的遗体送回家。然而，这项新使命很难让他们的家人和朋友理解。
They want you to move on with your life. They want you to get back to normal. My own brother said to me-- said, you're not the same as you were. I said, let me explain something to you. You're right. I'm not the same person. I never will be. They see it as we're obsessed with this. Well, we are, in a sense. We are obsessed with it.
他们希望你继续生活。他们希望你恢复正常。我的亲兄弟对我——说：你已经不是以前的你了。我说：让我跟你解释一下。你是对的。我不是同一个人。我永远不会是。他们认为我们对此着迷。好吧，在某种意义上我们确实。我们对此着迷。
The Phillipses and a few other parents told me, because it's so hard for people to understand that the grief never fades, old relationships start to fall away. People you were closest to disappear, which makes this informal support group even more crucial.
菲利普斯和其他几位父母告诉我，因为人们很难理解这种悲伤永远不会消失，旧的关系开始疏远。你最亲近的人消失了，这使得这个非正式的支持小组更加关键。
What that support looks like over time and what it means to the parents who get it, I've got to see all that when Sandy and Lonnie got to know a couple from Florida who lost their son in the shooting at Parkland. Annika and Mitch Dworet. I met them at their house.
随着时间的推移，这种支持看起来是什么样的，对得到它的父母意味着什么，当桑迪和朗尼认识一对从佛罗里达州帕克兰枪击事件中失去儿子的夫妇时，我看到了这一切。安妮卡和米奇·德沃雷特。我在他们家见到了他们。
Their son's name was Nick. He was the captain of Parkland swim team and was about to go to the University of Indianapolis on a swim scholarship. He was a six-foot tall blond kid who collected different flavors of Oreos and waited for supreme drops. Mitch said they'd just reached a point where they were becoming real friends. They talked about relationships, shared playlists, and watched Scarface together.
他们儿子的名字叫尼克。他是帕克兰游泳队的队长，即将凭借游泳奖学金去印第安纳波利斯大学。他是个6英尺高的金发男孩，收集不同口味的奥利奥，等待Supreme发售。米奇说他们刚刚达到成为真正朋友的阶段。他们谈论人际关系，分享播放列表，一起看《疤面煞星》。
The day of the shooting, Mitch and Annika got phone calls and texts all day from people who said they'd heard Nick was OK. One person said they heard he'd been moved to a staging area for all the students who'd witnessed the shooting. Another said a police officer was giving him a ride home. And then a nurse at a local hospital said she saw a patient who matched Nick's description. But by that evening, the Dworets' still hadn't heard directly from Nick, so they went to an area that law enforcement designated as a meeting area. They sat in a ballroom with other parents and waited.
枪击发生那天，米奇和安妮卡整天接到电话和短信，有人说他们听说尼克没事。一个人说他们听说他被转移到了一个为所有目睹枪击的学生准备的集合点。另一个说一名警察正送他回家。然后当地一家医院的护士说她看到了一个符合尼克描述的病人。但到了那天晚上，德沃雷特还没直接收到尼克的消息，所以他们去了执法部门指定作为集合区的一个区域。他们坐在一个宴会厅里和其他父母一起等待。
Every time the phone rings, you jump and think it's Nick calling from somebody else's phone. The media was calling you. Do you have any comments? Can we help you find your son? I was just like, yeah. And at 2 o'clock in the morning, we see this FBI car, and then they start pulling one family into a room at a time. And you hear screams from these rooms.
每次电话响起，你就跳起来，以为是尼克用别人的电话打来的。媒体在呼叫你。你有什么评论吗？我们能帮你找到儿子吗？我只是说：是。凌晨2点，我们看到这辆联邦调查局的车，然后他们开始一次把一个家庭拉进一个房间。你从这些房间里听到尖叫声。
Then their names were called out.
然后他们的名字被叫到了。
Even walking into that room, you have this tiny little hope that they're going to say, we couldn't even find your son, and that hope of that he was somewhere else. And I keep on thinking, maybe he walked home. And then you do the math in your head, like, doesn't take that long to walk to our house. And then they told us the news that he was gone. He was shot and he was never brought to the hospital at all-- just like a nightmare, just like a nightmare.
甚至走进那个房间时，你还抱有一丝微小的希望，他们会说：我们甚至找不到你的儿子，那种他可能在别处的希望。我一直想：也许他走回家了。然后在脑子里做算术，比如：走到我们家不需要那么长时间。然后他们告诉我们他走了的消息。他被枪击了，甚至根本没被送到医院——就像一场噩梦，就像一场噩梦。
Nick's body was still at the school because he died instantly, and the building was still a crime scene. It'd be two days before they could see him. Annika wanted to look at his injuries. Mitch did not.
尼克的遗体还在学校，因为他当场死亡，那栋楼仍然是犯罪现场。两天后他们才能见到他。安妮卡想看他的伤势。米奇不想。
Annika says, this is just how her brain works. She's an ER nurse. She needs details. The director at the funeral home, wanting to protect her, called the medical examiner's office to ask about Nick.
安妮卡说，这就是她大脑运作的方式。她是急诊室护士。她需要细节。殡仪馆的馆长想保护她，给验尸官办公室打了电话询问尼克的情况。
And the person that answered the phone said, oh, let me take a look. What's the name again? It's Nicholas Dworet. He's the swimmer. Oh, the swimmer's perfect.
接电话的人说：哦，让我看看。名字叫什么？是尼古拉斯·德沃雷特。他是那个游泳运动员。哦，游泳运动员很完美。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
I think it meant that there was nothing on his face or his head, like he was perfect.
我想这意味着他的脸上或头上没有任何伤痕，就像他很完美一样。
He'd been shot three times. A bullet in his chest destroyed his heart and lungs.
他被枪击了三次。一颗子弹击中胸部，摧毁了他的心脏和肺。
Was it helpful for you to see him?
见到他这对你有帮助吗？
Yes, it was helpful. Because your picture in your head, when you hear that somebody has been shot with an AR-15, just so gruesome, so horrible, horrible. And I think to see him and to see on his body where his injuries were made me get it, like he was so peaceful. And he was not in pain. And it made me have a better image of him than the one that was playing over in my mind.
是的，有帮助。因为当你听到某人被AR-15枪击时，脑子里的画面太可怕了，太糟糕了。我认为见到他，看到他身体上的伤势，让我明白了，他很平静。他没有痛苦。它让我对他有了比脑子里不断重播的画面更好的形象。
The Phillipses had traveled to Parkland a couple of days after the shooting. They didn't know the Dworets, but a mutual friend thought they should talk. And so this friend, with Mitch's permission, gave Sandy his phone number. Sandy called and got no answer, so she left a voicemail.
菲利普斯在枪击发生后几天去了帕克兰。他们不认识德沃雷特，但一位共同的朋友认为他们应该谈谈。所以这位朋友，在米奇的许可下，给了桑迪他的电话号码。桑迪打了电话没人接，所以留了语音信箱。
I'm very sorry for your loss. I understand your loss. We lost our daughter. And you can call me any time.
我对您的损失深表遗憾。我理解您的损失。我们失去了女儿。你可以随时给我打电话。
She let them know that she and Lonnie would be in Parkland for a few more days. Mitch called back quickly. He did want to meet with them in person, thought it would be helpful to talk to another family who'd been through a mass shooting. But he told Sandy the timing wasn't going to work. His house was packed with family in town for Nick's funeral.
她让他们知道她和朗尼会在帕克兰多待几天。米奇很快回了电话。他确实想亲自见到他们，认为与另一个经历过群体枪击事件的家庭交谈会有帮助。但他告诉桑迪时间不合适。他家塞满了为尼克葬礼从外地赶来的亲戚。
And I'm on the phone with him, and ironically, I'm standing right in front of his child's cross. And I said, you're not going to believe this.
我正在和他通电话，具有讽刺意味的是，我就站在他孩子十字架的前面。我说：你不会相信这个。
She said that she was standing right in front of Nick's memorial. I get chills right now.
她说她就站在尼克的纪念碑前。我现在还在起鸡皮疙瘩。
And we proceeded to have a talk. And he said, I don't think we're ready to meet with you. And I said, I totally understand. I'm just glad that we're getting to talk. But you do need to know that truthers are already online saying that this didn't happen. He said, what are truthers? And I said, ugh, OK.
我们接着谈了下去。他说：我不认为我们准备好和你见面了。我说：我完全理解。我只是很高兴我们能谈话。但你需要知道的是，真相寻求者已经在网上说这件事没有发生。他说：什么是真相寻求者？我说：呃，好的。
I thought like, wow, you kidding me? Crazy.
我想：哇，你在逗我吗？疯狂。
Mitch asked her to stop by their house the following day. While Mitch was on board with the Phillipses, Annika had a different take on total strangers stopping by their house.
米奇让他第二天顺道去他们家。虽然米奇同意菲利普斯来，但安妮卡对完全陌生人顺道到他们家有不同的看法。
I was more-- maybe more skeptical, like nervous of why are they here? What's their agenda? How can people come and meet with us if they don't want something from us?
我可能更怀疑，或者说紧张，他们为什么在这里？他们的议程是什么？如果他们不是想从我们这里得到什么，怎么会有人来见我们？
Their house was so crowded that the only private place to talk was their bedroom. Annika and Mitch sat on the bed, Lonnie and Sandy on chairs. Annika remembers feeling a little uncomfortable and thinking to herself--
他们的房子太挤了，唯一可以私下谈话的地方是卧室。安妮卡和米奇坐在床上，朗尼和桑迪坐在椅子上。安妮卡记得感到有点不舒服，心想——
Why am I sitting here? Why I'm not with the family? Who are these people? I don't know them. But I guess it might help. But it was very overwhelming. Like, I can't believe that I have to sit and have this conversation. What is this? This is my life now?
我为什么坐在这里？我为什么不和家人在一起？这些人是谁？我不认识他们。但我猜这可能有帮助。但这非常让人不知所措。就像，我不敢相信我必须坐在这里进行这种对话。这是什么？这就是我现在的生命吗？
Was there a point in the conversation where it started to turn for you?
对话中有没有一个点让你开始转变？
Yeah. I think when they said, don't join our organization now, don't fight now. Just take care of yourself and let yourself grieve.
是的。我想当他们说：现在不要加入我们的组织，现在不要抗争。只是照顾好自己，让自己悲伤。
They asked questions about Nick. And before long, they were just talking. Lonnie remembers Mitch asking if they were religious and if they ever got signs from Jessi. He told Mitch that, like them, they weren't, but they took 11:11 as a hello from Jessi. The conversation went on for three hours.
他们问了关于尼克的问题。没过多久，他们就只是在聊天。朗尼记得米奇问他们是否信教，以及他们是否从杰西那里得到过迹象。他告诉米奇，像他们一样，他们不信，但他们把11:11看作是杰西的问候。谈话持续了三个小时。
All our friends and family, as much as they did for us and how much love they showed, none of them could have any clue what we were feeling. And here were two people knowing exactly what we were feeling.
我们所有的朋友和家人，尽管他们为我们做了很多，表达了多少爱，他们都无法理解我们的感受。而这里有两个人完全知道我们的感受。
They also made me feel a little more confident. I don't know if that's the right word. You're in a club we all don't want to be in. We didn't want to meet you. We wish we would have met under different circumstances, but you have people help you with this kind of grief.
他们也让我感到更有信心了。我不知道这是不是正确的词。你加入了一个我们都不想加入的俱乐部。我们不想遇见你。我们希望我们在不同的情况下遇见，但有人帮助你处理这种悲伤。
And a few days later, when the online conspiracies started appearing about Nick, that he didn't exist or that he was living in California, they remembered Sandy's warning. It was still upsetting, but less upsetting because they knew it was coming. They've helped in other ways, too. The Dworets took the Phillipses' advice and got in to trauma therapy right away, both individually and as a family.
几天后，当关于尼克的在线阴谋论开始出现时，说他不存在或者他住在加利福尼亚，他们记住了桑迪的警告。这仍然令人心烦，但没那么心烦，因为他们知道它要来了。他们在其他方面也提供了帮助。德沃雷特听取了菲利普斯的建议，立即进行了创伤治疗，既有个人的也有家庭的。
Their younger son, Alex, has been through a lot. Nick was his best friend. One of the last things Nick did on the day of the shooting was walk Alex to his English class. Alex was injured in the shooting and sat by a kid who died right in front of him. Annika says managing her grief, along with her son's, has been tough.
他们的小儿子亚历克斯经历了很多。尼克是他最好的朋友。尼克在枪击那天做的最后一件事之一就是陪亚历克斯去英语教室。亚历克斯在枪击中受伤，坐在一个死在他面前的孩子旁边。安妮卡说，和她儿子的悲伤一起管理她的悲伤很难。
There was so much attention on Nick, Nick, Nick, Nick, Nick. Everybody came for Nick. The flowers were for Nick. The letters were for Nick.
所有的注意力都在尼克、尼克、尼克身上。每个人都为尼克而来。花是给尼克的。信是给尼克的。
I felt like I-- if this didn't happen to Nicholas and only this, I could have been there for Alex so much stronger and so much more. So I was afraid that he would get neglected in all that.
我觉得我——如果这件事没发生在尼古拉斯身上，仅仅是这样，我也许能更强大地支持亚历克斯。所以我害怕他在这一切中被忽视。
I think sometimes children feel like, well, you must have loved that child more than you love me.
我想有时孩子会觉得：好吧，你一定比爱我更爱那个孩子。
Sandy's son was 25 when his sister died. Sandy tried to talk to him about it, which ended up pushing him farther away. When she talks to parents, she talks about her own mistakes, too.
桑迪的儿子在女儿去世时25岁。桑迪试图和他谈论这件事，最终把他推得更远。当她和父母谈话时，她也谈论自己的错误。
Eight months after they first met, Mitch is still in touch with Sandy. They text or call each other every couple weeks. Mitch relies on Sandy more than Annika, who unlike him, already has a built-in network of friends she talks to all the time.
他们第一次见面八个月后，米奇仍然和桑迪保持联系。他们每隔几周发短信或打电话。米奇比安妮卡更依赖桑迪，不像他，她有一个内置的朋友网络，她一直和他们交谈。
And we texted-- I think we texted yesterday. It was 11:11 actually. We texted yesterday.
我们发了短信——我想我们昨天发了短信。实际上正好是11:11。我们昨天发了短信。
And I feel like she's still in it. She's still with us. It's someone who we can lean on and give us support. And I, in turn, want her to lean on me. Maybe seeing us get stronger, it gives her energy, too.
我觉得她还在里面。她还在陪着我们。这是一个我们可以依靠并给我们支持的人。而我，反过来，希望她也依靠我。也许看到我们变强，也给了她能量。
He's right about that. Sandy spends almost every day at her tiny kitchen table in her trailer, fielding texts and phone calls from survivors, and messaging with people on social media who ask for help.
他说得对。桑迪几乎每天都在拖车里的小厨房桌旁，处理来自幸存者的短信和电话，并与社交媒体上寻求帮助的人交流。
The pain is always there at the end of the day. And when you go to bed at night, when you first wake up in the morning, it's there. But you have a sense of purpose and that helps.
痛苦在一天结束时总是存在。当你晚上上床睡觉时，当你早上第一次醒来时，它都在那里。但你有一种目标感，那会有帮助。
A little bit of a lifeline or something?
像是一条生命线之类的？
Oh, it's a total lifeline, total-- if I didn't have this work, I don't think I'd be alive, I really don't. And I say that to Lonnie all the time. He goes, but don't you love me enough, kind of thing, to stay alive? I just don't think I would have had the ability to keep going.
哦，那是一条完全的生命线，完全——如果我没有这项工作，我不认为我会活着，真的。我一直对朗尼说。他会说：难道你不爱我到足够维持生命了吗？我只是不认为我有能力继续下去。
Mitch and Annika told me that when they're feeling stronger, they'd like to do for other families what the Phillipses have done for them. They said, god forbid another shooting happens. But if it does, we'll be out there with them.
米奇和安妮卡告诉我，当他们感到更强大时，他们愿意为其他家庭做菲利普斯为他们所做的事。他们说：上帝禁止再次发生枪击。但如果发生了，我们会和他们一起出现在那里。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show.
米基·米克是我们的制片人之一。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and Robyn Semien. The people who put the show together today includes Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Chana Jaffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Anna Martin, [INAUDIBLE], Miki Meek, Catherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克和罗宾·塞米恩制作。今天制作节目的人包括埃尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格拉夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳·贾菲-沃尔特、赛斯·林德、安娜·马丁、[听不清]、米基·米克、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。我们的高级制片人是布莱恩·里德。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿。
We had some original scoring in today's program by Matt McKinley. Special thanks today to Andy and Barbara Parker, Heather and Seth Adams, Nicole Hockley from Sandy Hook Promise, Michael Dorn of Safe Havens International, Harvey Shapiro and James Fox at Northeastern University, Carrie Klein, Kate [INAUDIBLE], Joe Eaton, and Jim Irvine.
我们在今天的节目中有马特·麦金利的原创配乐。今天特别感谢安迪和芭芭拉·帕克、希瑟和赛斯·亚当斯、来自桑迪胡克承诺的尼科尔·霍克利、来自安全港国际的迈克尔·多恩、来自东北大学的哈维·夏皮罗和詹姆斯·福克斯、凯莉·克莱恩、凯特[听不清]、乔·伊顿和吉姆·欧文。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. We also have an app that lets you download our entire archive and lots of other features. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，您可以完全免费收听我们超过600集的档案。我们还有一个应用程序，可以让您下载我们的整个档案以及许多其他功能。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）交付给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he was watching this documentary on rock and roll in the '60s, but it complained it was taking them forever, forever, to get to The Rolling Stones.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他当时在看一部关于60年代摇滚乐的纪录片，但他抱怨说，他们花了太久、太久的时间才讲到滚石乐队。
Oh, yeah, it was because you got to get through the doors.
哦，是的，因为你得穿过那些门。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - BAHAMAS, "NEVER AGAIN"]
[音乐 - 巴哈马，“永不再次”]
Never again, never again will I let you go. Never again, never again will I let you go. Never again. Never again.
永不再次，我永远不会再让你走。永不再次，我永远不会再让你走。永不再次。永不再次。